halle how are you this morning I'm doing
well dan how are you I'm doing great I
just don't know if I want first class
seat window look what Carson Wentz
bandwagon or am i still going to be in
coach right now where are you with
Carson Wentz in the bandwagon I'm on
whatever Airlines my son owns you know I
think I think wences it's such an it
were throwing the ball now more than
ever at every level said this many times
Pop Warner middle school high school
college and we're no closer to really
understanding or evaluating who the guy
is coming out it's harder and harder and
harder because we're doing it out of the
spread and for the most part
quarterbacks are looking at front
coverages to a great extent than not
huddling up it's not red zone it's not
blitzes it's not checked everything is
from the sideline it's on a wristband or
it's on a card this kid went had
elements of what you do at the next
level at North Dakota State nice I would
not be surprised in if every scout and
the league is out there trying to you
know take a look at quarterbacks that
are playing at that level because that
level of play has gone up quite a bit
and maybe there are some systems there I
mean when you're looking at big systems
you're figuring out what can I get a
ready-made guy well Stanford Michigan
State Florida State has elements Alabama
Wisconsin beyond that you're looking at
quarterbacks who don't take snaps under
center don't huddle up and don't really
understand fronts and coverages well I'd
sitting in exact science as you just
pointed out that we keep trying to look
at a guy and say he looks like he would
be a great quarterback instead of
somebody you know I always thought Doug
Flutie could play it just he didn't look
the part if if he's six
three Doug Flutie's a Hall of Famer but
nobody would give him a chance Russell
Wilson was great did everything in
college and then he gets to the pros and
people don't mean age it's not tall
enough and i always think both those
that you know and they are an anomaly
you know they are an anomaly and i think
death of those guys played in different
systems to what we have now you know I I
coach against Russell on high school and
Russell was 20 when he was 10 years old
he's been mature he's been smart he's
been poised he's been a leader he's been
a great player he was a great player
there I thought well you know who go to
North Carolina State and when I first
heard he was going to North Carolina
State I remember the conversation he and
i had that he was going there to play
for Coach O'Brien and he was a Virginia
guy and navy guy had been a BC but he
was an old school coach and I said he's
going to let you play quarterback and
baseball that surprised me and it ended
up being a problem but he was great down
in NC State he was a player of the year
the first year mainly go back to your
bench they needed to get up and they
said well you know we just don't think
it's right for you he goes to Wisconsin
with no spring ball ends up being the
captain and leads him to the Rose Bowl
that's a little easier to see Russell
was the kind of guy that can make the
transition his transition wasn't about
you know scheme or recognition it was
about measurables it was all about two
inches damned if he's two inches taller
asst she said he's top of the first
round but let me go back you were
coaching against Russell Wilson so
you're coaching your son's team in high
school yeah coach for eight years down
here in Virginia we couldn't beat him i
drew dan I drew evidence by side blitzes
spies four-man front three-man front man
coverage zone coverage you name it you
know we tried everything that you could
possibly do and he was just he's doing
right now he's doing exactly what he did
then and I and I always thought to
myself as big a fan as I was a Russell I
said you know it's going to catch
two min NC State you know it's going to
catch up to him to Wisconsin you know
when he gets the Seattle it'll catch up
to him and God bless him he's a
remarkable young man he's really is how
a long Fox NFL Sunday analyst Hall of
Famer joining us on the show you get the
good in the bad we all just this past
week your son playing for the Patriots
they win yeah your son playing for the
Bears they knows what's it like watching
you know it's it's no different dan you
know right you have you have children
you know and you I'm sure at some point
whether it's a sporting event or a play
at school or you know a a law debate
whatever it is I'm no different than any
other parent I'm I'm either sitting in a
stadium somewhere in a corner I'm in a
hotel room by myself squatting in a
chair and you know going through every
snap with them and it's like when he was
like how was on the mound and in Little
League or you know high school or you
know college the same thing with crisp
crisp for me has worked so hard and been
through so much over the last couple
years you know pops a tendon in his
ankle as surgery being a being a team
guy comes back plays on Bo essentially
one leg and same thing the following
year fractures his leg and you comes
back probably four or five weeks too
early and is playing on one leg and and
you know that's part of the process at
that age if you're injured you you move
on and he had an opportunity to go to a
number of different places and I kept
coming back to the same question why are
you playing and he's playing to win and
he went to the place to give it gave him
the least amount of definitive kind of
idea of what he would be doing well
or less money and and I'm not saying he
for him it's not it has nothing to do
with the money it's all about one thing
it's all about having the opportunity to
win and be a part of it and I've always
felt like he was that kind of a player
he's always been that kind of a player
because I'd like to think I brought them
up that way you don't think about the
money when you're playing think about
the money when you're laying in bed when
lights out at night and you're thinking
about the next payment on this or that
or you know how do i send the kids to
college or you know I've got an extended
family member I need to take care of
whatever it is he's he I've always felt
like I've been intrigued and fascinated
by how that team goes about their
business over the years how they prepare
the team first it's we versus me their
ability to change week to week have to
have quarter quarter series two series
and not just from a scheme standpoint
but also from a preparation standpoint
for each and every player to be able to
do that is I think it's fascinating we I
always say it's hard to put history and
perspective as it's happening and I
think 10-15 years from now Bill
Belichick will be viewed as not only the
coach of our generation but quite
possibly the best that's ever been we've
been discussing that with what Belichick
did last Thursday night I don't know
what he's going to do this sunday coming
up but it's almost done the good pay my
son's a good Patriot Danny gives me
nothing when he came on with us and you
know how we love Chris because he would
talk to you about everything he came on
all of a sudden he's got that cloak of
the patriotism hanging over him and I
said was that movie with ben affleck and
Morgan Freeman where they finally got in
the Russian nuclear facility and Morgan
Freeman said to Ben Affleck I you know I
sent five agents to get into this place
none of them came back you know I've
been trying to get in here for 25 years
that's me I've
trying to get in that building for 25
years I've just so fascinated by it and
I get nothing this sum of all fears i
think is the matter i get nothing maybe
do they have bring your dad to work
could he bring you to work like with the
Patriots there you know I've always as
you as I think you know I've you know
even when there's open practices I I
don't go you know I can see everything
on film and that's really what I'm
concerned about and I would rather watch
off to the side and by myself and you
know it's not like everyone makes that
talks about Peyton against Eli well
paint is not hitting Eli you know I've
had those listen I've lived it you know
when you get Kyle Chris and young Howie
who's who's liked or Tanaka he's
bringing in a foreign object from the
closet you know I mean he's 16 the buck
80 and you know Kyle 67 325 and you know
chris's 6-3 6-4 270 how he's got to go
to the he's got to go to the bag of
tricks as you do every Sunday with Terry
Bradshaw yeah well where we had that
lightning delay this week and we filled
for an hour and 15 minutes I think but
it was interesting though because as you
know in pre-games you talk in 15-20
seconds on bytes so that kind of a fill
for me is I use two percent of what i
read or looked at during the week in a
pregame format so for me was an
opportunity just to talk football which
is great it's great to talk to you again
as always and tell the boys at Fox we
set a low and we'll talk soon hopefully
i will you have you given those guys any
kind of a raise mainly because I mean
that shows been successful no no yeah it
all ships rise in a high tide doesn't JB
say that you know what they're they're
like the Patriots everybody's
interchangeable Howie oh I can be you
you
be there for all interchange about
therefore we're all replaceable yeah
yeah this is this is what happens here
and these guys know it and they're not
allowed to say anything as well they're
not allowed to talk to the media that's
the price for greatness yes it is thank
you how I partner hi thats Sarah Hallie
long hall of famer the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience